[Applauso]
[Musica]
a
puoi mettere in galera tutti quelli che
cantano una canzone
quello che non puoi fare è mettere
dietro alle sbarre una canzone le
canzoni blues hanno accompagnato la
durissima lotta degli afro americani per
la loro e per la nostra libertà
in questi tempi in cui tutto sembra
sembra cambiare così velocemente i
diritti umani i diritti civili vengono
troppo spesso dimenticati ci sono luoghi
in cui addirittura questi diritti non ci
sono nemmeno più e nessuno ci fa più
caso
sono passati poco più di 55 anni dal
giorno in cui martin luther king e il 28
agosto 1963 pronuncio a washington le
parole a dream
un discorso quello di martin luther king
il cui profondo significato espressione
di valori universali e ancora oggi
drammaticamente valido c'è stato un
tempo in cui nelle casette bianche
sperdute tre campi di cotone del
mississipi si fabbricavano armi
potentissime e micidiali le canzoni in
chiesa i neri facevano la rivoluzione
cantando cantando e battendo le mani
cantando canzoni come questa aiutatemi
glory glory
[Musica]
si sale ma senza lode
blue ridge aurei hallelujah senza alle
mappe zanzariera glory glory aloia senza
alle mappe i figli glory glory glory
glory glory glory hole and glory regione
due gare lo regione o cronica o lei o
lui a senza alle mappe
no
[Musica]
no no no no
no no no no no
o no
[Musica]
[Applauso]
c'è ancora
c'è ancora tanta strada da percorrere
per far diventare il sogno di martin
luther king realtà ma io io non ho mai
perso la speranza è davvero davvero
credo che una canzone ancora oggi una
canzone un'armonica a bocca possono fare
molto
tantissimo dentro dentro a questa
armonica c'è soffre della mia libertà
con questa armonica sono riuscito a
realizzare molti dei miei sogni di
ragazzo con questa armonica sono
riuscito a toccare il cuore di
un'anziana signora m s p che un giorno
di tanti anni fa mi disse e me you touch
ma mi hai toccato il cuore quella
signora quel giorno medie della laurea
che non ho mai avuto la laurea
all'università del blues la musica e
respiro la musica è vita la musica e
libertà ed è sogno però mi anch'io ho
avuto un sogno enorme quello di suonare
una canzone particolare sulla tomba di
martin luther king ad atlanta in georgia
e qualche tempo fa il mio sogno si è
avverato con grande commozione ho
suonato quella canzone là dove riposa il
grande uomo di pace che diceva puoi
uccidere
del sognatore ma non potrai mai uccidere
il suo sogno è qui a modena oggi voglio
portare la stessa canzone che ho suonato
in giorgia con la quale vi saluto e vi
ringrazio e vi abbraccio si chiama
amazing race
[Applauso]
[Musica]
no
mamma mamma mamma mamma
[Musica]
roma
all
[Applauso]
[Musica]